this exact 3 500 16 inch m1 max bucket  pro is going straight back to apple i  was sitting there contemplating how to  make the correct choice because of five  key points the first one was battery  life the 16 inch gets better battery  life the second was of course the screen  size the third was fan noise with the 16  inch running cooler and quieter then we  have actual real world performance and  the fact that the 16 inch is now 200  more expensive and after all of that  testing i was convinced that the 16-inch  is the right choice for anybody that  cares about performance but in the  coming weeks of use i slowly started to  change my mind every time i use the 16  inch after using the 14 inch what i have  found is that even though the 14 inch is  slower it is still fast enough for  everything that i throw at it there is  literally no other 14 inch machine that  packs this amount of performance into  this size on the market